skills is like sex you learn it by doing  it not reading about it and the reason  i'm making this example is because so  many people come to me and they're like  hey man what books do i need to learn to  read how to sell what courses do i need  to go through in order to learn how to  sell none of those things are going to  even come close to how much you're going  to learn after you take your first phone  consult your first phone call because  you won't even know what you're reading  about until you've actually done it and  so just like sex you have to actually  get in the game actually go through your  first 10 sales first 20 sales first 50  sales and then start learning how to  hone the craft and get better at it  because otherwise you don't even know  what you don't know